are you would you consider yourself a
feminist
yes okay do you think do you want
equality
yes
um so when it comes to equality do you
think that
women should make up like 50
of the military
no why if you want equality
i don't like i think i'm anti-military
so i don't really believe in like people
going to war like fighting and stuff
okay i also don't believe that like
women should have to force me like
should be forced to fight i do feel like
that men are physically able to do
things that like women would have to
train a lot longer to do so i don't
think it's fair to make a woman do those
kind of roles
and yeah like i feel like not all
elements of life have to be 50 50 for
equality to be there okay what so what
does equality mean to you like what do
you what do you think we're still like
fighting for in 2022 like equity like
equality
could work but like equity is like
making it work for like what's fair like
gold order
not have to be now she's not for it to
be equal like 50 50. so you don't
advocate for like 50 like all the jobs
should be 50 50. like when they talk
about like for example like met like
ceos and stuff that doesn't have to be
like 50 women 50 men
i feel like that's a bit different like
in the working world because like it's a
job and like most jobs nowadays well a
lot of jobs that um
a lot of men do i do think that women
can do as well like i don't think
there's like
like the military that's a very physical
job i think it's quite different but
like a lot of jobs aren't in that world
and i feel like those should be
accessible and those should be allowed
to have this 50 50 balance yeah well do
you
is there anything like stopping us today
to like become a ceo
what do you mean like so like like me
and you were girls yeah like if we
wanted to become a ceo we could right
yeah
so
um i'm just curious like what do you
think would stop us yeah i feel like um
a lot of people see men being ceo so
it's like that feeling that like oh i
didn't expect you to be the ceo like
okay believability like a lot of
businesses and like a lot of marketing
is like oh like people like believe in
like you're confident it comes across
that way and people kind of believe in
what you're saying a lot of people don't
believe in confident women like oh this
is a scam i don't believe what they're
talking about i don't trust what they're
saying because just because they're a
woman they don't believe that they're
capable i think that could stop someone
becoming a c wait who who doesn't
believe we're capable i feel like a lot
of people have that like stereotype or
like have this opinion that maybe they
were just not believable
as being like ceos do you so do you have
the same like belief like bricklayers
should be 50 women and 50 men and
plumbers and electricians or is it only
ceos
it depends on the job i mean i think
bricklaying i don't know how physical
the job is i have really no clue like
what they do apart from laying bricks
like i don't know what kind of demands
and like what kind of skills you would
need but if a woman wanted to be
bricklayer and she thinks she can then
why not but i do feel like some roles
maybe it's better to have more women in
those roles or maybe to have more men in
those roles yeah no i agree with you
like i think it should be but to me i
don't think there's anything like
stopping us from doing any role today
you don't think so no nothing i think if
i i think if i wanted to be a ceo i
could be a ceo i think you could but
yeah it'd be a lot more difficult in
comparison for when a man tries to
become a ceo but you realize there's
like specific grants for women that
aren't given to men that's true but i
don't
think to the next you're actually on an
event that was an all women's business
thing actually wasn't it that's true um
i'm going to take an event called um
yeah it's just not just for boys but
like
i don't think that that one event is but
that's like makeup for
yeah i don't think that makes up for
like majority of technology and it world
being like male dominated how do you
know the difference between women just
choosing stuff that they're interested
in
like for example i don't know a lot of
girls that want to be plumbers and i
used to work for a plumbing tech company
so we like sold stuff to plumbers and we
would go to schools and it would be like
one two plum like female plumbers in the
room and plumbers make a lot of money
right it's just not like a glorified job
but how do you know the difference
between women not um wanting to do those
jobs
and
and like discrimination because at the
other end of the spectrum like my dad
he's the ceo of a company and my dad
worked 80 hours a week my whole life to
get to that position right like since i
was i barely saw him my whole life i
don't know many girls that would want to
do that
like
so so
yeah
yeah like every house a week oh i
wouldn't like do you want to i don't
want to do that
but like how do you know that because
you're talking about like systemic like
like discrimination that's against us
but how do you know the difference
between women like choosing what they
want to do and just
and discrimination
i guess it's a difficult thing to figure
out i mean yeah it's hard to divide the
two it's hard to see the difference
between someone actually being really
motivated and like hard working and
really trying hard yeah i do think if
someone really tries hard
and really works maybe
hours a week they could get somewhere
yeah but i'm not gonna say it's gonna be
easy yeah and maybe a guy would have it
a lot easier than a woman if like if
you're if i was talking 80 hours and
your father was to work 80 hours i think
maybe there'll be a difference well i
don't um i actually i think it's easier
for women um i don't yeah because we're
offered like my um dad put his company
under my mom's name so we could get like
specific grants and like tax exemptions
like for women so they give us like an
easier path to it
i think i guess so i guess there's some
opportunities there i've been a woman i
do think my sister's an engineer oh yeah
i think that makes a huge difference
when she's applying she's like yeah yeah
she's a girl that's like
what what like 100 male applicants and
one woman like i think she's like one of
three in a whole like aerospace
engineering course that makes a huge
difference maybe she gets more attention
more support yeah there's more like
opportunities there but i do think in
the mail world yeah a place is male
dominated i don't want to be the first
woman in the room and being that i don't
think it's an easy job i feel like you
have to be like 120 better than
everybody else
i feel like the opposite i feel like
girls are given special treatment and
they're given stuff that they don't
deserve
because there's special grants for women
that aren't offered to men isn't that
special treatment
though that's like can i interject
go ahead go ahead
yeah we've been talking about here's my
here's my question to you yeah
okay um
do you think
it is
easier for women
to get a job than men
it depends on the job so if i want to be
a babysitter i feel like okay as a woman
i'd have like a great advantage a lot of
people want feminine people to look
after their children
but if it was a different kind of role
then maybe not
okay okay so
let's say i wanted to drive a tractor
or if i wanted to lay bricks and there
was a woman that was a man who do you
think would have the
higher chances of getting that role like
no skill set just no skill set just on
the get-go like if i apply and you apply
for a bring their job or a babysitter
job you would get who had a higher
chance of gaining
in my opinion
okay the person with the most dedication
and the most um uh
i want to say passion towards the job
okay we both have no experience and no
passion
there you go dedication because i think
that's personal bias
in a lot of cases
personally like i don't know because i
know a lot of people that do bricklaying
and plumbing and have a history of that
um but like
yeah i was gonna say like with a lot of
those grants they kind of
yeah in some cases like they're trying
to help out women because you know like
it wasn't that long ago it was but like
in terms of like
i don't know like um
like century-wise and like decade wise
there wasn't a lot of um
things for women but um
yeah a lot of it kind of
i guess kind of focuses on that and with
that focus
sometimes some like companies and places
will kind of like want to like show off
that and kind of hire more women or
diverse like just like to be
performative not to actually okay i
really do want to see women in this
industry it's just like okay we have a
quota we have to have at least 19 uh
women on this team let's just employ 19
women even though they're not qualified
yeah i do think that could happen i
don't think that's great but
but i think that's like i think that's
wrong i think like i don't think we
should try to make it
like 50 50. like i don't think we should
try to get women to do industry like
jobs they're not interested in like i
don't i don't know i don't know many
girls that want to be engineers i know a
couple my best friend from childhood
she's an engineer she hates it
i mean
i think that's true like yeah a lot of
people are like oh we need more women in
stem but do women want to be in stem do
you want to be i don't want to be on
staff
yeah but i guess it's just like um
there's something about um women are
more respected when they're like well a
lot of feminist viewers like women are
respected when they are perceived as
male so they act like males like a lot
of women um dress more masculine when
they go into a working world there's a
lot of males
as a feminist what do you want that's my
question to you like equity i want it to
be fairer and do you think that what did
you just say you said something about
him how you're viewed
you said something about how you're
viewed
what about it about how women are
like how women seem more masculine okay
yeah so
are you saying if you seem more
masculine you will get more respect from
a male
no i mean like
i think that was a concept of like
femininity like feminism i think it's a
bit dated now but maybe in like the 80s
and 90s like a feminist a real girl boss
was like a bit masculine a bit like
cutthroat a bit rude a bit you know
kind of like girl bossing and that kind
of like concept is like okay very
popular and i don't really connect with
that anymore i feel like a woman
shouldn't have to become the stereotype
of a man to be respected and to be equal
i think a woman can stay feminine she
doesn't have to go into stem she can do
what she wants but it to be like fair
that if i did want to do that like i'd
have the opportunities to do that
yeah i just don't understand like what
like what are we fighting for today you
can go into anything you want
i think like you can like what what's
stopping like because because
we like women women like what are we
working for so so i'm saying like like i
was born in 1996 i i've always been able
to vote i've always been able like i've
always been told since i was really
young to like do whatever you want like
you can chase after whatever career you
want i'm in i'm in a very male dominated
space in youtube i worked in a male i
was the only girl in my office in sales
and i feel like that was more of an
advantage than a disadvantage because
like one men are attracted to you they
want to help you like i think it's
easier for women
and so i just don't know like what are
we fighting for
okay i mean i'm not a woman but when i
think of all my friends and like the
only family members i have are women
when i think of like um
female problems i think a lot of them
are
um just personally from friends and
stuff like a lot of um
kind of this idea of like um feminism
and how it's like warped in certain
people's like minds okay also like
laws in terms of
like especially in like art because you
know there's some countries where
it's very different for women it's very
different yeah how they live but like in
terms of like our countries and that
um
like laws against you know like in
america there's um like abortion laws
and stuff and also like sexual assault
and how that's handed handled by the
police my social social services and
stuff which is kind of like
iffy in certain places
so i do think like maybe in the working
world we've got like quite far but like
just general safety of women's like if i
was like walk around alone at night in
london like obviously i feel like the
experience would be different for a guy
i do not believe you guys are saying
that's what yeah
sorry to cut you but i do not believe so
if you don't believe um that we're saved
and how are we supposed to believe that
like we're saved like jeremy like
everyone you realize men are more likely
to be victims of a violent crime than
women statistically like they're they're
more likely to be victims of a violent
crime that could be true but like the
men have this fear like do you have fear
like are you scared to walk around at
3am the difference between
us and you guys we probably fear more
than you guys fear you think so
walking down the street
i don't know 1am
they can still get mugged like they
could still get stabbed
like there's no crimes that will happen
but i just feel like there's a
vulnerability of being a woman
especially a woman that's like i don't
know maybe not
like i can't do any self-defense things
like i know like if someone wants to
attack me like that's it that that's the
end of the life
yeah do i have to do that no i i agree
with you like we're the weaker sex right
so we're not we're not as strong but but
the issue is again like what are we
fighting for like
safety like everyone wants to be safe
[Music]
so i just don't understand like what
legally we would be fighting for